the Disney Channels zombies movie needs
no introduction and especially not here
at the things you know you are all very
excited for zombies too and everything
that it has in store but in the meantime
we figured we'd give you guys some
theories to think about the specific
theory for today's video is something
that was never really explained in the
movie
why is Addison's hair white hey
everybody it's your o somewhere and
welcome back to the thing this video is
shoutout goes to our of amazing things
members Mary Carson James 44 for the
chance of a shout-out in our next video
be sure to LIKE subscribe and of course
leave a comment in this video now let's
get started
so as Seuss characters introduce twist
as you're not so typical high school
cheerleader she really wants to make her
parents proud and become a cheerleader
just like her cousin Bucky those freaks
are nothing like us I'm like Bucky
though Addison doesn't always believe
that different moves back she's actually
pretty different herself since under her
perfect flan wake her hair is actually
pretty edgy and white but today's my
shot at making the Seabrooke cheer squad
you make cheer and you fit it the movie
didn't really give us an explanation as
to why this was the case making us
believe that there is probably more to
this little detail than we initially
thought so with everything I was able to
dig up the only theory that really kind
of made sense was that Addison herself
was half human and half zombie now
before all you zombies fans lose it on
me in the comments let's get to the
factory Radisson to be hot zombie she
would need to have zombie blood flowing
through her veins
this totally could have been passed down
from her parents except for the fact
that they kind of do look normal and
don't really seem to be hiding anything
or wearing anyway now I don't know if
you guys have been paying attention in
your science process but we have things
called genes that show our traits and
sometimes they skip a generation
we know that the zombie do you can
definitely be passed down since we see
that zombie parents do make a zombie
children now the only other person who
could pass it down to Addison is
grandfather you might have found this
addison Buffy talking about how their
grandfather got bit by a zombie Addison
even plays it off as just a small bite
if not here's a clip to jog your memory
they tried to eat our grandfather it was
just a small bite a really cool detail
spotted by youtuber watt so videos is
that Addison does say that she tried all
sorts of things to fix her hair but no
dyes ever really seemed to stick when
looking at the entire zombie squad what
you might have noticed is that despite
their awesome outfits and super decked
out accessories they never really
thought to change their hair either they
were all happy just as they were with
their shades of green or they might have
had the same problem as Addison we also
know that zombies have some crazy human
strength when their Z bands are broken
we do get a glimpse of this when that
dries out for the football team and
catches Addison after a cheer stunt gone
wrong oh no I just wanted to thanks ed
for rescuing from the book if I ain't
got any of that crazy strength it
definitely would help her out with all
sorts of physical activities especially
cheerleading so if this theory does add
up it would totally make sense that
Bucky is the head cheerleader remember
that they both do share the same
grandfathers so it is totally possible
that they both inherited the gene and
now guys for the final reason why I
totally think that this theory could be
true it's what I like to call the Disney
motive Disney is not for putting all
sorts of sweet messages in all their
stories just a quick look at this movie
and you can already tell that it is a
story about two different kinds of
people coming together and putting aside
their differences you're gonna love this
okay
I see this but the movie was probably
trying to show us this in more ways than
just one instead of being overly sappy
and take away an awesome dance number
just for the sake of a moral the movie
might have just left us with something
to think about once the movie was over
if this theory is true and Addison is
half zombie then she can show all the
residents of Seabrook and zombie town
that sometimes being from two different
worlds means that you can definitely
have the
best of both not only does the sleep
fans of the movie with a warm and happy
feeling inside but it does give the
sequel's something else to talk about
for all the details on what you can
actually expect to see in zombies - be
sure to check out this video and of
course subscribe to the things I'm still
learning that zombies aren't what I was
taught now before you go I've got a few
questions for you guys to answer do you
think this theory holds up and Addison
could actually be part Sambi I'm gonna
need you to let me know why or why not
in the comment section below I also want
you guys to be sure to tag the zombie
cheerleader or maybe even hybrid of your
squad do not forget to get fun and
creative for the chance of a shout out
in our next video it's your little
snores don't forget to hit me up on
social media at Norma bean and I'll see
you guys next time
[Music]